เนื้อหาสวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้อง
อาร์ตี้นักเรียนเย้กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้กู
พี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม prensa เบิ้ลไทยนะครับ
อ้าวันนี้ขับ
หน้าวันนี้เรามาเจอกันวันนี้วัน
มันอะไรคะขออะตีวันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่
30 วันที่ 30 เป็นวันสิ้นเดือน
สิ้นเดือนคือจบเดือนนี้แล้วจะไปเดือนหน้า
จะไปเดือนใหม่ล่ะเป็นวันสิ้นเดือนโอเคนี้
จังเลยวันสิ้นเดือนเงินก็ออกจากวันสิ้น
เดือนเงินเดือนออกอ๊อฟพรุ่งนี้วันที่ 1
วันต้นเดือนใจกับพรุ่งนี้เริ่มต้นเดือน
ใหม่เรียกว่าต้นวันต้นเดือนใจมันต้นเดือน
วัน
การใช้ไง
ไปเที่ยวใช่ไหมครับไม่ได้เอาเงินไปจ่ายไป
จ่ายค่าบ้านจ่ายค่าไฟให้ค่าน้ำค่า
อินเตอร์เน็ตค่าอะไรไม่ทราบ
โอเค
โอเคค่ะครูปาร์ตี้วันนี้วันสิ้นเดือนแล้ว
นะคะพรุ่งนี้ก็ออกวันต้นเดือนนะคะเนี่ย
เมือกวันสิ้นเดือนเดือนอะไรนะคะเดือนนี้
เดือนนี้ยังเป็นเดือนมิถุนายนอยู่ครับปีพ
ศอะไรนะคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับปีคศอะไรคะข้อ
2022 ครับต้องคัน 22 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
อ่ะตอนนี้ 8:00 น 8:00 กี่นาที
40  7:40 นไม่ใช่ไหมครับ 5 อ่าโอเคทุ่ม
40 นาทีตอนกลางคืนกลางคืนเฮ้ยครับเรามา
นัดคุยกันตอนกลางคืน
ใช่เขาอ่ะต่างกลางคืนกูเจอกับพี่เอ๋เจอ
ตอนกลางคืนประจำเลยตอนกลางวันนะคะแต่เขา
จะเจอครูเรียมตอนกลางวันน่ะ
ควรติ๊กหาเราวันนี้คลิปนี้ครู Arty จะพา
ไปเที่ยวที่ไหนคะค่ะคลิปนี้เดี๋ยวจะพาไป
เที่ยวออกภาคเหนือครับภาคเหนือของประเทศ
ไทยเพราะว่าคลิปที่แล้วครูเอ๋พาไปภาคใต้
ถ้าคิดจะขึ้นมาพังงาข้าวนี้กลัวที่จะพา
ขึ้นไปภาคเหนือครับอามาที่นี่ครับเหนือ
สุด 1 เนื้อที่สุดของประเทศไทยเลยครับคน
เอาขวดตีมันทีเราจะพูดใช่ไหมขึ้นเรื่องนะ
ลองใต้อ้าใช่ครับขึ้นเหนือก็คือไปภาค
เหนือตายก็ไปภาคใต้ไทยครับถ้าล่องแปลวัน
ลงขึ้น
ล่องเนี่ยลองตายจุดนะเกลือไปได้ไงเหลือ
กับๆลองอยู่เหลือไป
โอเคค่ะค่ะอาทิตย์หน้าเดี๋ยวจังหวัดอาไบ
เที่ยวจังหวัดเชียงรายครับแย่สุดของ
ประเทศไทยในครับเราด้วยหน้าหนาวนิดหน่อย
ครับหนาวนิดหน่อยเวลาที่เราพูดถึง
เชียงรายคู่เอกคิดถึงอะไรครับเชียงรายหรอ
ให้หายเชียงรายกูอีกคิดถึงอาหารๆๆคิดของ
กินก่อนเลย
YouTube กูเอกคิดถึงที่เที่ยวใช่ไหมนะ
ครับเป็นที่นาเชียงรายเชียงราย
ชอบที่ 1 ครับไม่รู้ว่าตีนี่รูปหรือเปล่า
รอที่ไหนครับ
อ๋ออ๋อดอยแม่สลองควรติดไม่ได้เอารูปมาไม่
เป็นไรหรือเป็นไรนะคะอ่ะอ่ะเอาใหม่เอา
ใหม่สามเหลี่ยมทองคำ
ถ้าเป็นสามเหลี่ยมทองคำเนี่ยมีเพราะว่า
เพราะว่าตรง
จังหวัดเชียงรายเนี่ยจะมีรอยต่อของ 3
ประเทศอยู่ค่ะมี 3 ประเทศอยู่ที่นี่ใน
ครับอ่ามีประเทศอะไรบ้างครับพี่เอ๋ประเทศ
ไทยประเทศเมียนมาร์ประเทศลาวใช่ครับมี 3
ประเภทตรงนี้ครับตรงนี้เป็นหน้าควรที่
เขียนหน้าตรงนี้เป็นพม่าอ่าตรงนี้เป็น
พม่านะแล้วก็ตรงนี้เนี่ยเป็นประเทศไทย
5 ส่วนตรงนี้ฝั่งตรงนี้อ่ะก็จะเป็น
ประเทศลาว
มากเปล่าประเภทมันเจอกันตรงนี้ก็เลยเรียก
ว่าสามเหลี่ยมทองคำๆเป็นสามเหลี่ยมทองคำ
อยู่ตรงนี้เดี๋ยวตัวตั้มเป็นสามเหลี่ยม R
ประเทศนะคะองค์สามเหลี่ยมทองคำเนี่ยอ่า
บางฤดูกาลนะครับแม่น้ำทางสายนี้กับสายนี้
เนี่ยแม่น้ำจะมีคนละสีกันครับจะเป็นคนละ
สีกันมันคือแม่น้ำอะไรกับแม่น้ำอะไรให้กู
เอกจะเอาไหมฮ่าๆๆๆเอากูอยากจะนิโขงป่ะอ้า
เป็นแม่น้ำโขงด้วยครับแม่น้ำโขงแล้วก็แม่
น้ำที่สาละวินป่ะ
ใช่ครับใช่ครับสาละวินจะมาจากป่าจากป่าคน
ละคนละที่กันถ้าปากคนละที่ก็จะมีดินคนละ
สีกันนะเวลามาเจอกันก็จะมองสังเกตเห็นได้
ว่าจะเป็นน้ำมันจะเป็นคนละสีพ่อเป็นแม่
น้ำสองสี
248 เจอกันตรงสามเหลี่ยมทองคำตรงนี้ค่ะ
ไม่นานว่าจะไหนไปคนละทางห่าอามารวมกันตรง
นี้อะไรมารวมกันรวมกันนะๆอะไรมาที่นี่ไม่
ใช่สาละวินและแม่น้ำอะไรกูเองไว้นะจ๊ะ
โอเคแม่น้ำสองแม่น้ำแล้วนะเนี้ยโอเคตรง
นี้ก็จะเป็นเอ่อที่ท่องเที่ยวที่หนึ่งที่
คนชอบมามาดูประเทศลาวประเทศพม่าใจกับหน้า
อ่าเมย์ออกตอบพานักท่องเที่ยวเด็กนั่ง
เรือล่องแม่น้ำไปดูวัดต่างๆไปเที่ยวที่
โน่นที่นี่ใส่กับคนไหนก็จะไปแล้วถ่ายรูป
นะคะถึงแล้วสามเหลี่ยมทองคำ
หนัก
หนาอะไรนะครับไปอ่ะกูอตี้สมัยใหม่นะคะนัก
เรียนนานมากเลยใช่ไหมอะที่ยังไม่เกิด
นักเรียนมีคนต่างไม่เกิดเอาช่วยไปล่ะป้าย
ก็จะไม่ใช่แบบนี้แล้วก็
ไม่มีที่ยืนสวยๆแบบนี้ค่ะเป็นดิน
ดินนะครับ
ตอนนี้สวยมากๆเดี๋ยวนี้เขาอ่ามีที่พักมี
ร้านอาหารมีที่ท่องเที่ยวเยอะที่นี่แล้ว
ครับแล้วก็แอบบอกนิดหนึ่งมีมีบ่อนคาสิโน
ด้วยเฮ้ยคนไทยขึ้นอ้อไปก็อยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะ
อ้าวไม่ได้อยู่ในฝันไทยไม่ได้อยู่ประเทศ
ไทยก็เพราะว่าประเทศไทยเปิดบ่อนไม่ได้ผิด
กฎหมายสิบมาหายไม่ได้อยู่ลาวได้ครับไม่
ได้อยู่เมนต์มาอยู่ตรงเกาะ
ได้ครับอยู่ตรงกลางวีมีเกาะอยู่ตรงกลาง
อ่าโอเค
โอเคค่ะแล้วมีอะไรอีกชาร์จหน้าเดี๋ยวเอ่อ
เอ่อถ้าเป็นอีกที่หนึ่งที่ครัวตี้เมื่อ
ก่อนตอนที่น่ากลัวติ๊บพูดถึงเชียงรายครัว
ที่ก็จะคิดถึงที่นี่เป็นที่แรกครับสมัย
ก่อนนะสมัยก่อนกลัวที่จะคิดถึงที่นี่ครับ
ที่ไหนเอ่ยอ่าที่นี่เนี่ยเป็นที่ที่แม่
ของในหลวงเนี่ยชอบไปอยู่ในหลวงในหลวงที่
เท่าไหร่ขายหลวงรัชกาลที่ 10 บาทในหลวงคน
ที่สิบของประเทศไทยคนที่ 9 คนที่
995 ๆคนไทยจะเรียกว่าสมเด็จย่าเพราะว่า
เป็นแม่ของในหลวงค่ะนะคะในหลวงรัชกาลที่ 9
นะคะๆครับนี่พลบิดหน้าเราเรียกว่าสมเด็จ
ย่าๆนะคะเรียกสมเด็จย่าอ้าว 5 สมเด็จย่า
ชอบไปอยู่อีเมล์ครับอะไรคะที่นี่ที่นี่
ชื่อดอยตุงครับอ๋อ
แล้วที่นี่ก็ก็จะมีดอกไม้สวยๆเยอะมากน่ะ
เป็นสวนดอกสุดท้ายควายว่างใหญ่ใช้ครับเรา
เข้าไปได้ไหมคะอ่ะเข้าไปได้ครับเข้าไปได้
เข้าไปเดินเล่นไปถ่ายรูปตรงนี้ข้างในมี
ร้านขนมร้านขายของฝากชายหาหมอแต่ก็จะมี
บ้านเป็นบ้านของอ่ะแม่ของในหลวงรัชกาลที่
9 หรือสมเด็จย่าๆได้ครับมีกระตำหนักดอย
ตุงอ่าใช่ครับเป็นพระตำหนักนะครับบ้านเรา
เรียกของเรามาบ้านของสมเด็จย่าเราเรียก
ว่าเป็นพระตำหนักอ่ะพระตำหนักดอยตุงก็
อยู่ที่ดอยตุงนะครับอ่ามึงจะบ้านสวยเป็น
บ้านแบบมีกาแล้วใช่ครับถ้าเป็นคนเหนือ
เวลาปลูกบ้านเนี่ยตรงซุ้มยอดหลังคาก็จะมี
อ่ะตรงนี้เรียกว่ากาแลใช่ไหมครับอ่ะใช้
ครับสวยดีสวยมีมีสวนสวยมากได้มีสวนดอกไม้
สวยมากกว่าที่ไปเคยไป 2 ท่านก็สวยทุก
ครั้งเลยใช่ครับดอกไม้ทุ่งดอกไม้กว้าง
ใหญ่มากวันที่ชอบดอกไม้นะคะถ้าตอบครับ
เป็นผู้ชายหวานนะคะ
โอเคแล้วไปๆกันไปใกล้กันอยู่ที่ดอยตรง
เหมือนกันครับมีอีกที่หนึ่งที่อ่ะคนไทย
หลายๆคนบางคนก็มีความเชื่อว่าเวลาที่ตัว
เองเกิดในในราศีเกิดปีกุน
High อาเกิดปีกุนเนี่ยต้องไปที่นี่ครับ
ต้องไปที่วัดมิทิราอาร์เป็นวัดพระธาตุดอย
ตุงค่ะไปทำอะไรคะต้องไปไหว้สักการะที่นี่
เขาบอกว่าถ้าคนที่เกิดปีกุนมาไหว้พระธาตุ
ที่นี่จะทำให้รุ่งเรืองโคกดี
ทำงานก็ดีต้องขึ้นขึ้นเงินเดือนก็ดีใจก็
สบายเออพระถ้าได้ตรงไหนล่ะที่เรียกว่า
อยู่ตรงนี้ครับก็จะมีอยู่ 2 องค์ค่ะอาสาย
พันธุ์นะถ้าจะอยู่ในเจดีย์ใช่ไหมคะอยู่ใน
เจดีย์นี้นะครับจะไม่เห็นเราจะเห็นแต่
เจดีย์ข้างนอกนั่นเองครับพระธาตุก็คือ
กระดูกใช่ครับใช่ครับมาดูนะคะจะดูของพระ
หรือว่าพระพุทธเจ้าที่ที่ลีบพานไปแล้ว
แล้วก็เอาไปใส่ข้างใน
ที่นี่เขาบอกว่าเป็นพระธาตุที่บาร์จาก
กระดูกกระดูกที่อยู่ตรงนี้ครับกระดูกไห
ปลาร้าตอนนี้ครับของพระพุทธเจ้า
5 อยู่ที่วาดรูปกระดูกนึงได้ไหมคะอ้าวาด
รูปกระดูกใช่ไหมครับอ่าได้เลยก็จะมี
เดี๋ยวนะอ่าเป็นกระดูกธรรมดาก็ได้เป็นก็
จะมีกระดูกอยู่ตรงนี้ครับเวลาคนคนจะมี
กระดูกซี่โครงนี้ใช่ไหมเหมือนไอ้ห่ามีแขน
ตรงนี้อ่าโอเคกระดูกตรงนี้ครับ
กระดูกไหปลาร้าตรงนี้คือก็คือเหมือนกับ
พระแขนตรงเนี้ยนะโอนเลยนะออกไปข้างในอ่ะ
ค่ะนักเรียนก็เป็นกระดูกอ่ะทรายงามข้างใน
เป็นประเทศที่แล้วก็เนี่ยอันเนี้ยเปิดใน
กระดูกที่อยู่ตรงนี้ไงตรงนี้อ้าเป็น
กระดูกไข่ของขวัญที่เห็นชัดก่อนตรงนี้เลย
ครับอันนี้ค่ะอ๋อกระดูกตรงนั้นหาของพระ
พุทธเจ้า
ใจครับนาอยู่ในเจดีย์อันนี้
คนเกิดปีหมูปีกุนใช่ครับพี่หมูพี่หมูก็มา
ไว้ที่นี่จะดีมากแล้วแล้วรูปปั้นข้างหน้า
ที่พนมเบอร์อยู่เนี่ยอ่ะลูกบ้านนี้เป็น
เทวดาที่ที่เขาคิดว่าเป็นเทวดาที่คอยปก
ปักรักษาวัดที่นี่วัดดอยตุงที่นี่ซ้าย
ครับเราจะไปไหว้ในครับ
ใส่ชุดสวยมากนะครับของเทวดานะครับมะรืน
นี้ก็เนื้อหาใด toung ตัดด้วยเนาะมีร่มมี
ถาดอ้าก็อ่าที่ชื่อพี่ชื่อดอยตุงตรงเนี่ย
แปลว่าธงอ๋อ
อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้คือธง
กองของคนที่เชียงรายเขาจะนิยมเป็นคงแบบ
นี้อาจเป็นพงษ์ที่แสดงถึงความโชคดีๆก็จะ
มีธงแบบนี้ถ้าไปที่ที่ดอยตุงก็จะเห็นคน
แบบนี้เยอะแยะมากมายเห็นตู้เยอะๆทรายเขา
จะเรียกว่าตุงอ่ะแต่คนภาคกลางก็ช่วย What
ธงธงๆอาจจะคนที่นั่นก็เรียกว่าตุงเป็น
ภาษาเหนือๆ
มีอะไรอีกคะจังหวัดเช่นแน่ๆครับเดี๋ยวพา
ไปที่นี่อีกครับพูดถึงเชียงรายตอนนี้กลัว
ติ้งคิดว่าหลายๆคนน่ะนักเรียนหลายๆคนน่า
จะคิดถึงที่นี่มากกว่าที่ไหนคะอ้าที่นี่
ครับ
หวัดดีก็เป็นอีกวัดนึงใช่ก็อ่าเป็นวัดสี
ขาวใช่ไหมครับวัดอะไรคะภูอติวัดนี้ชื่อ
ชื่อวัดร่องขุ่นครับ
วัดร่องขุ่นนะครับชื่อร่องขุ่นแต่ไม่คุ้น
เลยสีขาวมากสวยมากอ่าวใช่ครับสะอาดสวย
แล้วก็จะมีอ่าหวัดดีเคยไปหรือยังเนี่ยอ่ะ
คนที่เคยไปเคยไปน่าจะประมาณ 2 รอบไม่เคย
ไปเลย
ไปอาอาสวยมากครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้เขาสร้าง
เพิ่มเพิ่มมีศาลามีโบสถ์เพิ่มขึ้นเยอะมาก
แล้วใช่ครับเมื่อกี้กูอันที่บอกว่าอะไรนะ
ถ้าอะไรนะมีอะไรนะที่นี่
ครับวัดร่องขุ่นนะพี่จะบอกว่ามีอะไรนะอ๋อ
อาทิวที่วัดร่องขุ่นนี้ได้ไหมครับอ่า
สร้างจาก We  Are ศิลปินคนหนึ่งที่เขาวาด
รูปเก่งมากๆแวนโก๊ะอ่าเป็นศิลปินวาดภาพ
เหมือนกันแต่ไม่ใช่แวนโก๊ะ Van  gogh ไม่
ใช่คนไทยหลายคนเนี่ยเป็นศิลปินคนไทยครับ
อ่า
นี่ครับเป็นศิลปินคนนี้ครับสวัสดีค่ะ
อาจารย์เป็นอาจารย์ใช่มั้ยคนไทยคนไทย
เรียกว่าอาจารย์หมดเพราะว่าเขาเก่งมาก
เก่งอะไรนะคะที่อาจารย์เฉลิมชัยครับหน้า
วาดรูปเก่งมากค่ะนักเรียนมารูปสวยมากป่วย
มากกูแอบชอบมากแต่ว่า
ซื้อไม่ได้
ทำไมซื้อไม่ได้ครับเขาไม่ขายเลยนะของ 2
อย่างค่ะหนึ่งไม่ขาย 2 แผงแพงมากเลยให้
ฟรี
ทักคุยคุยแล้วชอบอาจารย์อ่ะเล็กๆให้นะคะ
รู้เก่งมากค่ะนายครับวาดรูปดีมากเพราะว่า
อ่ารูปของเขาเนี่ยเขาพยายามวาดรูปที่ไม่
เหมือนกับใครเลยค่ะไม่เหมือนกับที่มีเคย
มีคนวาดมาว่าเขาต้องการให้รูปของเขาเนี่ย
เป็นรูปเหรอมีรูปเดียวอ้ะมีรูปเดียวแล้ว
ก็เป็นเอ่อเป็นลักษณะที่เป็นกระเพาะเฉพาะ
ของรัชกาลที่ 9 ตอนนั้นอ้าใช่กับเท่านั้น
ก็เลยเป็นที่ที่แตกต่างจากคนอื่นมากเลย
คือเขาเกิดในรัชกาลที่ 9 ใช่ครับหลวง
รัชกาลที่ 9 เนี่ยนะก็
หลายคนก็เรียกว่าพ่อเนาะอ้าใช้ครับเป็น
ข้อหลวงไงหลวงนะคะคนทางเหนือเขาก็จะเรียก
ว่าพ่อหลวงพ่อเข้ามาเกิดว่าแม่ของในหลวง
รัชกาลที่ 9 ก็เรียกแม่ฟ้าหลวงไหมหาใช่
ครับแม่ฟ้าหลวงทั่ว
คะดังนั้นเนี่ยเขาก็จะวาดรูปใช่ไหมคะว่า
รูปให้เป็นรูปเฉพาะว่าในอยู่ในรัชกาลที่ 9
ๆใช่ครับสีอะไรก็จะออกมาสวยงามมากนะมาก
นักเรียนพรแพงมากมาได้เงินปั๊บก็เอาไปทำ
วัดค่ะหาแถวเงินไปสร้างวันครับจังหวัดนะ
ครับ
มันเป็นวัดขาวที่สวยที่นักเรียนเข็นนั่น
น่ะคะใช่ครับก็เป็นวัดควรตีคะข้างในวัด
เขามีเขามีอะไรนะพิพิธภัณฑ์รูปของตัวเอง
ด้วยใช่ไหมคะถ้ามีครับมีมีพิพิธภัณฑ์รูป
ของของอาจารย์เฉลิมชัยอยู่ด้วยเข้าปิดใน
ไหนอยู่ในบริเวณวัดอาร์มตอนที่ผมไปเนี่ย
ยังเข้าไปดูไม่ได้ตอนนั้นยังไม่เสร็จแต่
ตอนนี้ผมคิดว่าน่าจะเสร็จแล้วแต่ว่า
อาจารย์อาจารย์เฉลิมชัยเนี่ยต้องการที่จะ
ทำเป็นหอศิลป์อยู่นั่นอายุใกล้ๆวัดนั่น
แหละในบริเวณนั้นด้วยเหมือนกันตอนนี้น่า
จะเสร็จแล้วค่ะนี่คือบางรูปเนี่ยดูได้นะ
คะแต่บางรูปดูไม่ได้แต่ที่ห้ามเลยค่ะคือ
ถ้าเข้าไปดูรูปเครื่องดื่มห้ามเอาเข้าไป
เนาะๆๆกับ
โอเคค่ะถ้าอย่างดูรูปสวยๆก็ไปวัดร่องขุ่น
พายอาร์วัดร่องขุ่นของอาจารย์เฉลิมชัยนะ
ครับเหรียญอ้อที่เชียงรายเนี่ยยังมี
ศิลปินอยู่คนนึงอ่าศิลปินที่เก่งมากๆอยู่
อีกคนนึงนะคนนี้ก็วาดรูปเหมือนกัน
รูปของอาจารย์เฉลิมชัยเนี่ยอ่อนช้อยอ่า
ใส่กับสวยงามซอย 4 หวยดูแล้วสบาย
กับส่วนอาจารย์อีกท่านหนึ่งเป็นยังไงคะ
อาจารย์อีกท่านหนึ่งจะรูปของเขาก็จะดู
แข็งแรงเข้มแข็งมีพลังครับอยู่ดำขาวดำ
ส่วนใหญ่ส่วนใหญ่อาจารย์อาจารย์ทั้งนี้
อาจารย์ถวัลย์โทรหาอาจารย์ถวัลย์ถ้าจะวาด
รูปสีขาวดำใช้แล้วก็จะเป็นรูปที่เกี่ยว
กับสัตว์ค่ะ
สื่อถึงคนหลังถ่ายครับมาเป็นพันลังของอ่า
มืด
กี่ด้านเมื่อคืนแล้วก็ด้านสว่างเลยครับดำ
ร้อนและดำ
คนนี้รูปรูปของอาจารย์ถวัลย์ก็แพงเหมือน
กันครับแพงเหมือนกัน
ซื้อไม่ได้เหมือนกันครับเรียกว่าศิลปิน
ไทยที่ที่มีฝีมือแล้วก็รูปแห่งๆต้องมี
จริงๆนะคะใช่ครับ
อันนี้ค่ะลูกหัวจันทวัฒน์สวยท่านก็มีบ้าน
มีอาจารย์ถวัลย์มีบ้านอ่าใช่ครับมีบ้าน
อาจารย์ถวัลย์ในเปิดบ้านให้เป็น
พิพิธภัณฑ์ด้วยทำให้มีแต่พันธุ์เพราะว่า
ตอนนี้เนี่ยตอนนี้อาจารย์ถวัลย์เนี่ยเสีย
ชีวิตไปแล้วนะครับขอสร้างชีวิตไปแล้วมี
กี่ปีที่แล้วนะประมาณกวนที่ทำไม่ได้น่าจะ
ประมาณ 5-6 ปีโดยประมาณค่ะไม่หนาวนะไม่
ได้ไม่นานไม่นานไม่นานก็เลยอ่าบ้านของ
อาจารย์ก็เปิดเป็นพิพิธภัณฑ์เพราะว่า
อาจารย์น่ะสะสมสะสมผลงานศิลปะต่างๆไว้มาก
มายไม่ใช่เฉพาะของอาจารย์ถวัลย์คนเดียว
เป็นต่างๆทั่วโลกด้วยค่ะอ๋อก็ซื้อมาๆใช่
ครับเอามาไว้ที่บ้านบ้านอาจารย์ถวัลย์ใช่
วันที่เคยไปนะคะที่นี่ที่ไม่เคยไปบ้าน
อาจารย์ถวัลย์ขอโทษนะคะครับ
วาดรูปขาวดำบ้านก็เป็นสีดำอ่ะคนไทยจะรู้
จักบ้านก็จะนะหวานในนามว่าจะที่ว่าบ้านดำ
มันดำ 5 พิพิธภัณฑ์บ้านดำอยู่ที่เชียงราย
หนาในเข้
าแล้วก็อ้าเดี๋ยวนะพาไปเที่ยวบ้านศิลปิน
มาเยอะแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวพาไปที่ไหนครับหาไป
เที่ยวธรรมชาติบ้างดีกว่าไปที่นี่ครับ
ฮ่าๆไป
เดี๋ยวพาไปไร่ชาครับจิบน้ำชาอุ่นๆแล้วอ่ะ
จะได้ไม่อาย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
5 ที่นี่ใกล้ทาที่นี่โกตี้คิดว่าอ่านัก
เรียนน่าจะเคยไปคู่ a ต้องรู้จักที่เนี่ย
ฮะเสียมิเตอร์ต้องรู้จักที่ยังไงคะ
สวยมากดาวให้กูเอดส์เดาแม่ระมิงค์หรอ
ไร่ถาดถุยฟองเท้าก็เห็นไหมที่เห็นร้องอ๋อ
ๆเออรู้จักแน่นอนนะครับที่นี่เพราะว่า
เป็นไร่ชาที่กว้างมากไม่งั้นคุณภูเขาใช่
อยู่บนภูเขาที่นี่เนี่ยกูอันตี้เขามีที่
บ่อยากใกล้ๆไหมหรือว่าเราไปดูเท่านั้นอ้า
มีที่พักครับมีที่พักหาดมีที่พักมีร้าน
อาหารร้านกาแฟขายช้าขายอ่าผลิตภัณฑ์หรือ
ขนมต่างๆที่ทำมาจากชาที่อยู่จากในไร่
เนี่ยครับมีอะไรบ้างอ่ะอ้าวใจหานักเรียน
เข้าไป
กินของกินน่ะ
ส่วนใหญ่ก็จะเป็นขนมครับกินคู่กับน้ำชาอา
มิชาเขียวแล้วก็ชาที่เป็น R สีฉากหน้าสี
ชาดช้านะหาอะนิเค้กมีเค้กมีเครปนะคะครับ
ที่ทำมาจากเป็นชาด้วยนี้ใช่ใช่ครับวันที่
เคยไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะกลัวที่ยังไม่เคยไปที่
ไร่ชาร์จไฟฟองนะครับเพราะว่ารู้สึกตอน
นั้นไปขับรถไปเชียงรายไปเอ่อดอยตุงแล้วก็
มาแวะวัดร่องขุ่นจะหมดเวลาแล้วครับใช้
เวลา 2 วันหมดเวลาแล้วไปไร่ชาฉุยฟงไม่ทัน
อาหารวัดร้องขุ้มที่เป็นวัดสีขาวเนี่ย
กว่าตี้อ่ะอ่ะเอาจริงๆนะถ้าจะเดินให้ทั่ว
วัดเนี่ยต้องใช้เวลาประมาณเท่าไหร่คะ
โอ้โหอ่าตอนนั้นเนี่ยที่ครัวตี้ไปเนี่ย
เอ่อเขายังมีอยู่ประมาณ 3 ที่ 3 จุดที่
ต้องเดินไปมีห้องน้ำแล้วก็มีโบสถ์อันนี้
มีเอ่อที่พักผ่อนอีกที่หนึ่งและตอนนี้มี
มากกว่านั้นแล้วมี 5-6 ที่เพิ่มขึ้นมาแต่
ถ้าจะไปเดินให้ทั่วดูรายละเอียดเนี่ยผม
ว่าน่าจะมีสัก 1 วันนะครับ 1 วันเลยนะคะๆ
เริ่มตั้งแต่เก้าโมงเช้าเลยใช่จะให้ตั้ง
แต่เปิดเลยจะได้เข้าไปดูในหอศิลป์ด้วย
อ่านแล้วค่อยออกมาดูวัดดูรูปแล้วก็มาดู
อ่ะต้องใช้เวลาใน
[เพลง]
มีอะไรอีกคะอ้าเดี๋ยวนะครับเรามีเวลาอีก
นิดหน่อยเดี๋ยวกลัวตี้พาไปนี่คิดว่าและ
นักเรียนน่าจะเคยได้ยินที่นี่ครับอ่า
เพราะว่าเคยมีเหตุการณ์เหตุการณ์หนึ่งที่
ดังมากเลยที่ในประเทศไทยหาที่เที่ยงราย
นี่ครับอ่า
ก็
คุณน้ำนางนอนมีเหตุการณ์อะไรครับที่ขุน
น้ำนางนอนนะมีเด็ก 13 คน 53 คนที่นั่น
เข้าไปในถ้ำใช่ไหมอ่าเสร็จแล้วตอนเข้าไป
เนี่ยตอนเข้าไปในถ้ำอ่า
ฝนยังไม่ตกแล้วเวลาเข้าไปแล้วเนี่ยฝนตกพอ
ฝนตกเป็นไงครับน้ำไหลเข้ามาในถ้ำหน้าแล้ว
เด็กๆก็ออกจากถ้ำไม่ได้แล้วทีนี้นะก็เลย
ติดอยู่ในถ้ำแล้วเราทำยังไงให้เด็กออกมา
คะตอนหน้าเราก็ต้องช่วยกันครับตอนนั้นมี
เด็กอยู่ตรงนี้ครับหัว
หน้าอ่ะตีว่า
5 เด็กเข้ามาติดอยู่ตรงนี้
ตอนแรกเนี่ยเห็นนะมองเห็นไหมกลัวตีบ้าง
ไหมเห็นไงเห็นหน้าไม่บางนะโอเค
ตรงนี้เป็นตอนตรงจุดที่เด็กเดินเข้าไปค่ะ
เดินเข้าไปแล้วฝนตกพอฝนตกน้ำก็ไหลก็ไป
เด็กก็เล่นนี้นี้มีก็ไปน้ำก็ตามเข้ามา
แล้วก็หนีออกมาน้องเขาเข้าไปขึ้นในถ่าย
ออกมาไม่ได้ตอนนั้นอ่าน้ำเนี่ยก็น้ำเต็ม
ตรงนี้ปั๊บเนี่ยก็ต้องเดินเข้าไปเรื่อยๆ
แล้วน้ำก็ตามมาอีกอันนี้เข้าไปเรื่อยๆ
อย่าไปอยู่ตรงนั้นหาเข้าอยู่ข้างในสุดเลย
ทรายค่ะน้ำก็สูงขึ้นเรื่อยๆน้ำก็สูงขึ้น
สูงขึ้นจนในที่สุดก็ออกมาไม่ได้มากครับ
น่าก็เลยเป็นเรื่องดังไปทั่วโลกๆใช่ครับ
มีสร้างเป็นหนังอีกด้วยนะครับ 5 สร้าง
เป็นหนังด้วยเอาไว้ให้ต้องให้คนที่เก่ง
เรื่องดำน้ำมาแล้วก็เข้าไปเพื่อช่วย 13
คนออกมาตายนะ
ก็ใช้เวลาหลายวันเนาะหายใช้เวลาหลายวัน
ใช้เวลาหลายวันเพราะว่าจะมีคนเยอะเลยค่ะ
นักเรียนทั้งคนที่ดำน้ำเก่งทั้งทหาร
ทั้งคนที่ดูดน้ำดูดน้ำออกได้ครับก็
ก่อนอยู่ที่ถ้ำขุนน้ำนางนอนทุกวันนี้ก็ไป
เที่ยวได้แต่หน้าฝนไม่ไปนะ 5 ฝนจะมีน้ำ
เราไปรับน้าบ่นเค้าก็ไม่ให้เข้าไปตอนนี้
ต้องปิดเอาไปต้องปิดนะคะเลยให้เที่ยวอยู่
ข้างหน้าให้น่าจะเป็นเป็นหมูตัวที่ 14
อาจจะไม่มีใครเข้าไปช่วยฮ่าๆๆหมอเขาจะปิด
ค่ะก็จะมีป้ายก็จะมีปิดเลยตอนนี้ไม่ให้
เข้านะครับได้ครับแต่ตอนที่ตอนที่เปิดให้
เข้าถ้ำข้างในก็สวยมากนะครับห้ามบริเวณ
ข้างในถ้ำก็จะสวยมากเข้าไปดูเข้าไปเที่ยว
ได้เป็นธรรมดินลึกเข้าไปหรือมากใช่เข้าไป
มีใครเข้าไปไหมอ่ะดิไม่เคยเข้าไปไม่เคย
เข้าไปนะติ๊กคิดจะเข้าไปมั้ยคะเอ่อกลัว
ติมไม่อยากคบใครกลัว
เปิดดิคอยู่อ่ะกูเอกก็ไม่ชอบเที่ยวถ้ำ
เพราะว่าในถ้ำมันมืดในถ้ำมืดมองอะไรไม่
เห็นต้องใช้ไฟฉายอย่าไปครับแล้วก็ไม่รู้
ว่า
รู้ว่าในถ้ำมีตัวอะไรหรือเปล่ามีงูหรือ
เปล่ามีมันแรงแปลกๆหรือเปล่าชายก็เลยคิด
ว่าเราเที่ยวข้างนอกดีกว่า
ได้ครับโอเคก็เป็นแต่ว่าเป็นที่หนึ่งที่
สวยนะคะๆครับมีความตื่นเต้นก็ใหม่ที่นี่
ได้นะอะไรครับบางคนก็ชอบเที่ยวถ้ำนะบางคน
ก็ชอบเที่ยวทำหน้าแต่ยังครัวตีก็ชอบ
เที่ยวเป็นวิวธรรมชาติแค้มป์ปิ้งอะไรพวก
นี้ไม่ชอบที่มองเห็น
ที่มองเห็นกับเนี่ยมือมืดไม่ไม่เอาหมื่น
ในไปมืดอันตราย
รู้แต่จะมีที่เที่ยวอื่นอีกใช่ไหมคะที่จะ
มิมีอีกครับมีอีกที่เชียงรายมีที่เที่ยว
เยอะเพราะว่าเป็นจังหวัดที่อยู่เหนือสุด
ของประเทศไทยส่วนใหญ่ก็จะมีภูเขาตรงนี้
ครับอ่ะมีที่อีกที่หนึ่งที่เป็นที่ที่
ขึ้นชื่อของที่อาร์เชียงรายที่นี่ครับ
ชื่ออะไรนะคะอ้าที่นี่ชื่อภูชี้ฟ้าครับ
ชีสผีไปพี่ฟ้าแสง 5a อยากไปที่นี่มากกู
Arty รู้ไหม
คงไม่ฝ้าอยากไปอยากไปแปลว่าก็ยังไม่เคยไป
หน่อยน่าใช่ of  Pooh สีฟ้าต้องเดินขึ้น
ใช่ไหมใช่ครับต้องเดินขึ้นไป
แต่เขาบอกว่าเดินขึ้นง่ายกว่าที่เลยอ้า
ง่ายกว่าภูกระดึงทำงานก็พูดนะคะกวนตีเคย
ไปหรือยังคะคนที่ยังไม่เคยเดินขึ้นไปที่
ภูชี้ฟ้าครับค่ะยังไม่เคยไปหาแต่เขาบอก
ว่าสวยมากกว่ามองลงนัดว่างในรูปเนี่ยเห็น
เหมือนมีเมฆอยู่ข้างล่างสูงเหนือเมฆ 15
แล้วอยู่บนแม่อีกทีนึงนะ
ก็อนาคตนะคะอนาคตอนาคตคิดว่าน่าจะได้ไป
ครับหน้า
เขาบอกสวยมากอากาศดีมากที่พูดสีฟ้านะคะมี
อีกไหมคะรึฮ่าฮ่า
เวลาเรามีครับเดี๋ยวพาไปที่สุดท้ายครับ
เนื่องจากจังหวัดเชียงรายเนี่ยเป็น
จังหวัดที่ติดกับประเทศพม่าวันเวลาที่มี
จังหวัดที่ติดกับประเทศเพื่อนบ้านเราก็จะ
มีเป็นตลาด
ตลาดที่เป็นเราเรียกว่าตลาดชายแดนครับค่ะ
อ้าตลาดที่ไปที่มีชื่อเสียงมากครับเป็น
ตลาดแม่สายครับให้ครูเอกมัยแบบแม่สายใช่
ไหมมันไปแม่สาย
ที่ฝั่งไทยแล้วก็ฟังเหมือนมากใช่ครับหน้า
มีทั้งสองฝากก็มีแม่น้ำตรงกลางๆครับก็ถ้า
ผ่านไปก็ไปแวะซื้อของฝากของอ่าพม่าได้
พร้อมพื้นบ้านก็มีนะครับถ้าเราไปอ่ะเราก็
ต้องมีบัตรมีพาสปอร์ตไหมได้ค่ะเป็น
พาสปอร์ตเอ่อชั่วคราว
หมอเด้อผ่านไปนะๆครับก็คือเป็นคนไทยนะคะ
อะไรไปก็ถ้าสมมติไม่บางคนไม่มีพาสปอร์ตก็
จะมีมีมีเป็นตู้น้องแล้วก็ผู้เขียนมีบัตร
ประชาชนเขียนๆๆเป็นเป็น Border  Pass
ผ่านเข้าไปใดๆ 1 วันนะคะแล้วก็ตอนไหนก็
กลับมากับปรีใหม่นะไม่ฟรีนะไม่มีค่ะไม่
ฟรีประมาณเท่าไหร่ที่เอกเคยไปรู้สึกมันจะ
อยู่ที่ 100 บาทนะครับประมาณประมาณ 100
ครับแล้วถ้าเป็นชาวต่างชาติต้องมี
Passport นะคะจ่ายซ้ายเอาชาวต่างชาติ
ต้องมีพาสปอร์ตอยู่แล้วครับไม่งั้นก็ไม่
เข้ามาประเทศไทยอย่างช้าจะไปที่เนี่ยค่ะ
คุณต้องชม passport ละเข้าไปแล้วเข้าได้
เฉพาะตรงแม่สายแล้วก็ออกมา
เข้าไปซื้อของ
แล้วพอเข้าไปอ้ะเค้าจะมีรถรถที่เป็นรถแค่
ค่ารถทัวร์ก็จะบอกป้าไปเที่ยวไปเที่ยว
อะไรย่างกุ้งไปเที่ยวที่ไหนไม่รู้ค่ะตัว
เองเคยเคยไปนะแล้วเข้าทั่วไปๆตัวเองไปไม่
ไปดีแต่ถ้าไปเนี่ยใช้เวลากไก่ไม่รู้ไง
เดี๋ยวกลับออกมาไม่ทันรถทัวร์กลับ
กรุงเทพฯก็เลยไม่ไปขอ
หืออาทิตย์หน้ามีของขายเยอะมากนะๆใช่มี
ของขายเยอะมากครับเป็นของที่ผู้หญิงชอบ
อ่ะค่ะผู้หญิงชอบตลาดทุกพี่ครับแหวนแหวน
งั้นอ๋อๆเพราะว่าของพม่าจะมีพวกเครื่อง
เงินเครื่องประดับ
ที่เป็นของสวยงามแหวนสร้อยกำไล
ผู้หญิงชอบนะคะ
สาย
ครูบาติ๊บไปซื้ออะไรหรือว่ากว่าที่ไปดู
ครับอ่ะไปดูแล้วก็ซื้อของใช้นิดหน่อย
หน่อย
อ้าโอเควันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วครับอ้าอะไร
เยอะนะครับที่เชียงรายนะครับโอ้สัปดาห์
นี้อ่ะใต้
ที่พังงาก็มีที่เที่ยวเยอะหามีที่เที่ยว
เยอะได้ครับหน้านักเรียนนี่ไปกันที่ต้อง
แบบเชียงรายน่าจะต้องไปหลายๆวันบางคนก็
บอกอยู่ 1 เดือนได้ไหม
อยู่ได้ให้เขาอยู่ 1 เดือนก็ได้อาจจะได้
เที่ยวเชียงรายเพียงใหม่แถวนั้นก็จะมีที่
เที่ยวเยอะเหมือนกันที่ภาคเหนืออ่าใส่ค่ะ
สำหรับคนที่ชอบอากาศดีๆเราก็เชียงรายนะคะ
หมดเวลาแล้วหมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยวคราว
หน้าเรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่เดี๋ยวเราจะพาไป
เที่ยวที่ไหนคอยติดตามกันคลิปหน้าครับได้
ขายขวดพี่แอ๊ดพีพี่เอกก็ลาไปก่อนนะครับ
สวัสดีครับพี่เอ
ทำนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย